MARK MIRCHANDANI: Analysts
and data scientists
are often dealing with data
that's complex and not ready
for immediate analysis.
In fact, they spend
almost 80% of their time
cleaning and preparing data.
Accelerating this process helps
businesses be more responsive
with data-driven decisions.
That's where Google
Cloud Dataprep comes in.
Dataprep is an
intelligent data service
for visually
exploring, cleaning,
and preparing both structured
and unstructured data
for analysis.
It's a browser-based
service and works
at any scale with
no infrastructure
to deploy or manage.
In this lab, you'll use Dataprep
to manipulate a data set.
You will import data sets,
correct mismatched data,
transform data, and join data.
If this is all
new to you, you'll
know what all this means
by the end of the lab.
And it'll only take
you 45 minutes.
With Cloud Dataprep, you
can easily prepare big data
for things like training
machine learning models,
studying visual
analytics, or for
powerful interactive
queries that
unlock insights from your data.
This lab is part of the
baseline data ML and AI quests
on Qwiklabs.
Completing all the
labs in this quest
earns you this badge to
recognize your new skills.
You can show off your badge
on your resume or social media
channels.
Next on our quest, Google
Cloud Datalab Qwik Start.